[Música]
[Aplausos]
cheguei nessa casa
orai por 9
eu olhei para os quatro cantos o
miserável nobres a que mora um devoto do
divino espírito santo
ora e por nó
pobre quando eu cheguei nessa casa hora
e por nobre três coisas eu vim fazer o
miséria é nobre
vim contava em saudar e também agradecer
hora e pornô
obre eis essa é uma das tantas canções
que embalaram a minha vida eu sou filha
de artistas
eu cresci em meio à cultura
minha infância foi brincar crescer
estudar com arte em um quintal cheio de
arte e esse lugar que eu carinhosamente
chama de quintal ele ele está aqui no
maranhão ele está aqui são meses
ele é o grupo laborarte eo laborarte
para quem não conhece esse ano vai
completar 45 anos e lá tem teatro tem
dança tem música tem cultura popular tem
uma escola de capoeira tem teatro de
bolso é ponto de cultura já foi
cineclube
eu falo isso tudo pra gente sentir pra
gente ver a imensidão de quintal vasto
com vasto ele é
e nesse quintal tinha atores tinha
coreanas tinham mestres tambor zeros
artesãos artistas plásticos e antes de
tudo
da cultura eles são pessoas são pessoas
nas suas dificuldades nas suas emissões
nas suas realidades nos seus contextos e
essas pessoas estavam no meu quintal e
eu brinquei com elas
eu aprendi com elas e passei a admirá
las nesse quintal também tinham duas
pessoas muito importantes que se destaca
das demais que são minha mãe e meu pai
ora como filha de artistas né
não tinha quem ficasse com a gente em
casa e nós enviamos para o nosso quintal
por laboratório e sai a tem na estudar
estudar arte ea minha mãe é uma pessoa
de uma empatia fantástica
a minha mãe se conecta com as pessoas lá
sente as pessoas principalmente se essas
pessoas forem humildes se as pessoas
tiverem sofrimento se elas estiverem com
dor
a minha mãe consegue se conectar com
elas
o meu pai ele já faleceu
meu pai era uma pessoa que o que me
ensinou de mais importante foi acreditar
em pessoas
ele acreditava em cada um de vocês em
cada um de nós do que nós podemos ser e
ele trazia isso à tona
independente da sua dificuldade
ele trabalhava isso pra vir à tona e
essas pessoas todas os dois mestres as
pessoas que estavam no meu quintal e o
meu quintal me ensinaram que a cultura
pode transformar pessoas pode
transformar vidas pode transformar o
mundo e tem tem diversas histórias
quintal mas tem uma bem emblemática que
é da minha com maggi e à minha comad
chegou lá e ela estava com 23 dias que
tinha tido o quarto filho dela e quando
ela chegou lá no grupo
ela não tinha perspectiva para além de
se embriagar e festa
então todo dia era dia de bebê e festa é
beber cair e levantar pra lá de novo
beber cair e levantar e aí ela foi fazer
uma audição com o espetáculo amiga dela
levou ela pra fazer uma audição ela
ficou
ela passou na audição e e ficou nesse
espetáculo foi conhecendo a casa e
aquela vivência com a arte e com o
nelson nelson meu pai foi moldando ela
foi transformando ela e aí ela começou
vários filhos mais novos e depois foi
ficando com um espetáculo foi ficando
para outros o atacou
e aí saiu fez um curso técnico começou a
trabalhar com arte deu aula de de teatro
da aula de artesanato é professora hoje
né num é no cade um centro desses que
ficam na periferia e também comprou a
casa dela
isso não sou eu que conto é a reprodução
do que ela me diz tudo isso foi a arte
que proporcionou para ela e também
proporcionou para os filhos dela
ela conta que dos 4 os três mais novos
que ela levou para vivenciar a arte
todos eles não têm nenhum problema
nenhum trabalha com arte mas se
encaminharam e o mais velho que
vivenciou muito pouco esse espaço ou
quase nada
ele é dependente químico e uma das
coisas que ela reproduz é essa ele
vivenciou porque esse espaço
ele teve pouco acesso a isso e aí ele
ficou ela mora no bairro de periferia e
ele fez uns amigos e se encaminhou para
a dependência química
mas por que eu trago esse contexto eu
trago esse contexto reforçar essa tese
de que a arte pode mudar as pessoas e eu
também quero trazer uma perspectiva da
cultura mas a perspectiva da cultura
para além do fazer artístico
a cultura na admissão mais ampla dela a
cultura no dia a dia a cultura que a
gente vive a gente vivencia a cultura
que permeia essas relações que nós temos
os nossos contatos com os outros
e quando eu consigo enxergar a cultura
nessa amplitude
nessa dimensão eu consigo ver todo o
papel dela à cultura
ela transforma porque ela é vivida
ela te permite externar sentimentos
reais ou imaginários vivencia isso
imaginário há consentimento imaginário é
vocês conhecem aquele quadro o grito
assim o que é que esse quadro te passa
que esse quadro passa pra vocês eu quero
ouvir vocês que é que o quadro passa pra
vocês
pavor medo desespero espanto quando olha
a cena do quadro que consegue sentir a
cultura que permite sentir um sentimento
imaginário mas quando tu alcança esse
sentimento não consegue se colocar no
lugar do outro e consegue sentir o outro
e quando senti o outro passa a enxergar
do paço a ver aquela pessoa por inteiro
na dificuldade dela na alegria na
felicidade nadou e quando eu vejo o
outro e eu compreendo ele eu começo uma
transformação começa a ser mais impacto
eu começo a querer mostrar pra ele
tudo aquilo que ele tem e que naquele
momento de agonia e de desespero ele
pode não tá vendo
eu começo transformar aquela minha
relação porque aquela transformação de
compreender
ele já me transformou e eu começo
transformar aquela relação ea partir do
momento que eu comece transformar ele
essa relação eu começo a me transformar
transformar o meu entorno transformar as
pessoas que estão ao meu redor
eu comecei uma transformação no mundo
no todo é isso que a cultura faz
ela transforma o mundo passar a minha
gente tem é que vem lá a peteca o seu
cacuriá homem a gente quem é que tem lá
até convenceu patury a minha gente quem
é que vem na água até com o seu 14 a
minha gente quem é que vem lá lá até
convencer 14a
o dique do coroa essa mulher nós
ativamos manhã até quando ela canta sua
voz para cantar grande magia assim vaga
pelo ar
minha gente quem é que bem narrada na
peteca o setor fature a ouvir a gente
quem é primeiro
a dona teté com ou sem bateria ou bem a
gente tem é que bem lá lá uma peteca o
seu categoria vem a gente quem é quem
a nota técnica o seu cacuriá bobagem
essa aqui quem souber cantar junto com a
gente assim o jovem que sabe ler e não
sabe escrever e pré-pago o windows of dc
e ele lippi jabuti sabe ler não sabe
escrever de trepada o paulistão sabe da
sé
ele lê
ele lê estou saindo
[Música]
[Aplausos]